[Music]
first time i heard where's the love was
on much music
in like 2003. you know we've been having
this conversation over the past few
weeks whether it's a song or a speech
a piece of written text whether it was
2003 or 1973
you know where this message is still
relevant today
why did you choose this particular song
to speak through i think
it's still one of my favorite songs to
this day so i thought
being a musician we can't go out and
tour we can't go out
and and play shows yet this crazy thing
is happening right now with covid but
also this black lives matter movement
i needed to use my voice in the best way
that i know how
which is which is being creative and
trying to you know
trying to bring light to a situation
that is so heavy and that is so dark
i feel the weight of the world on my
shoulders as i'm getting older y'all
people gets colder there are some people
out there that say there's no racism in
canada you know not like in the us
what do you say when someone comes out
with a statement like that is it
frustrating
not anymore and here's let me tell you
why carlos it's not frustrating anymore
because i've decided
i'm gonna focus on the positives in less
than a month there has been so
much change change in terms of sports
change in terms of gosh in the in in the
states the confederate flag
is no longer acceptable it's not a thing
anymore
you can't justify that so to explain it
to people um that still don't get it up
here
it's it's tough you try to explain the
best you can but
it's exciting now because
you can see in real time the change is
starting to happen
i didn't feel necessarily represented in
country music so it wasn't something
that i was going to you know
that something i gravitated towards but
for you
when did you see people start to
question your line of work
you know questioning your type of music
and and now people are like
yeah that's cool i get that once people
hear the product
right everybody's quick to judge
something that they're not that they're
not familiar with
so i feel like with my music and my
sound um
i've really i feel like i've done a
pretty decent job
um kind of separating myself from uh
from the pack so the transition has been
in in
terms of the industry has been right out
the gate i was accepted right up
i think it was exciting that something
new um was coming up